I'm not usually a person who has trouble expressing herself with words.
I usually know exactly what I wanna say and how I wanna say it
around a lot of different topics.
In the next few days,
if you are a follower of mine,
you are going to start to see
me promoting the gofundme of a family from Gaza.
I have partnered with Operation Olive Branch and passed the hat
and have been given a family to help
escape the violence that they are experiencing in Gaza.
As I do that, I'm going to also be trying to educate about how you can
support the people in Gaza
without succumbing to anti Semitism
and without spreading hate speech in your comments.
I have found, especially for progressive Jews,
that we are very, um,
supportive of the civilians right to self determination to civilians,
right to dignity,
to humans, right to life.
But we also have noticed that a lot of y'all have not yet unpacked
your antisemitism
or the antisemitism that exists within our culture
in order to be fully effective without doing Undo Harm.
Now I'm going to do this purely for educational purposes
because I think it's important.
There are a lot of people talking about how to combat
anti Semitism on this app,
but a lot of them are doing it from a pro Israel standpoint
in my opinion.
Unfortunately,
I think that just causes more
black and white team type mentalities with both of these issues.
Because you can believe in the dignity of all humans.
And there's a lot of people on both sides
that are ignoring the humanity of each other.
I wanna help people.
I want to help civilians.
And as a Jewish American,
of course, that includes the hostages,
but it also includes the gossems,
who are undeniably being killed at a much higher rate at the moment.
You focus on who needs the most immediate help immediately,
and that's what I'm doing.
If you wanna find out more about Operation Olive Branch
or pass the hat,
you can go to Aaron's page.
I'm gonna tag her down below.
And I hope that you will consider donating
to the family that I've been assigned.
And if you simply wanna have conversations about
activism without doing undue harm, um,
I hope you stick around, because I would like to navigate this together.